folks it's that time of year again to
make a list this is my list of my
favorite things i've been listening to
this year i'm going to present my 10
favorite songs and albums of the year so
far in alphabetical order so let's go
ahead and get started with the songs
first up is a pick from an album that
didn't make the cut for me but i know
will for a lot of people it's snow
globes from black country new road
next on the opposite end of the spectrum
from an album that i know a lot of
people are hating it's massive from
drake
[Music]
this next one is very emotional song
that stopped me in my tracks the way
nothing else quite has this year this
one is brothers from gang of youth but
if he forgives him
then i should
too
next up we have a song that i guess has
released but kind of hasn't released so
a lot of you may not have access to it
or may not have heard it but it's uh
from kanye's donda two it's lord lift me
up which is technically a vory song more
than it is a kanye song but it's great
[Music]
next from kendrick i was kind of torn i
almost wanted to go with silent hill
because that song is so infectious but i
gotta go with father time
[Music]
[Music]
next on the list from leon bridges and
prong bin is chocolate hills
[Music]
next from pusha t i have to go with the
most classic kanye beat i've heard in
years aptly titled dreaming of the past
drum line like grambling mgm gambling
blew a small mansion and lastly from
tyler the creator and nego it's come on
let's go
moving on now to my top 10 albums of the
year so far in alphabetical order the
first one is going to be the sprawling
and expansive album from big thief
dragon new warm mountain i believe in
you
[Music]
i honestly have no idea how i can
remember that title but i do next up
yeah it's a controversial one and it's
one i'm gonna have to make a video
explaining but it's drake with honestly
never mind don't give up
between us next one up for me is gonna
be earl sweatshirt sick it's pretty low
key which is kind of par for the course
from earl but honestly it's one of my
favorites from him in a while
i'ma need a bigger bag for the cohort
trying to make a million next is
probably one of the popular albums that
i've really enjoyed this year but it's
fka twigs with capper songs
[Music]
next on the list i have everybody's
favorite australian band they've never
heard of gang of youths with their album
wow i actually forgot the name of the
album it's angel in real time
[Music]
probably no one's surprise and another
album that i feel i have to make a
longer video on so that'll be coming too
but it's kendrick lamar with mr morale
and the big steppers the dad chose
humanity over religion the family got
closer next up is the always psychedelic
and hypnotic every man kurt vile with
watch my moves
[Music]
after kurt i've got a bit of a country
album which is kind of a departure for
me but it's really good so i can't deny
it it's going to be orville peck with
bronco running from the curse of the
blackened eye
next up is a rap album that front to
back pound for pound is probably the
tightest and most efficient i've heard
this year and that's going to be pusha t
with it's almost dry really do you see
the phoenix rise from the ashes
lightning struck twice and finally
another one that might cause some
controversy because i feel like for
people that actually speak spanish this
doesn't rank very highly but given that
i don't understand it uh rosalia's moto
mommy that's going to go on this list as
well
so
so there's 10 and 10 of songs and albums
i wanted to throw in some quick
honorable mentions for each category one
project that can't make the album's list
because it's an ep that texas moon from
leon bridges and krong been really good
check that one out
at last an honorable mention for my
songs i want to throw in this little
skit i made a buddy over at not real
music ryan asked me to make this skit if
you like this definitely go check his
video out because there's going to be a
lot of skits from a lot of other
creators for all these different songs
thanks for watching this let me close
this out with hopefully a laugh we'll
see
hey orville it's rough criminal really
excited for the party tonight i've heard
your cooking is really good can't wait
to see what you're cooking up for us
i'm going to head to the grocery store
before i go to yours was going to see if
there's anything you need me to pick up
[Applause]
okay time got it yeah i'll pick some up
and then i'll head to yours uh can't
wait to see you also i invited chuck d i
hope you don't mind he's got some
thoughts on elvis he wanted to share
with you it should be fun all right take
care bye